[Music]
a real-life Treasure Hunt is underway in
New York City but not for gold or silver
dive teams are searching for something
even rarer the Priceless bones of some
prehistoric creatures Nancy Chen went
along for the dive Nancy yeah this is
pretty wild isn't it good morning to you
all how they got there though and if
they're actually there at all is up for
plenty of debate but that hasn't kept
these Adventures from heading down into
the water to find out
the search for elusive hidden Fortune
has long captured the imagination of
Thrill Seekers from the fictional secret
Chambers full of gold and the
Blockbuster film National Treasure
real life cold and rather murky Waters
of New York City's East River
these modern day treasure Hunters are
looking for this woolly mammoth fossils
50 tons of Bones and tusks from the
extinct species that last roamed the
Earth about 10 000 years ago they were
possibly dumped in the river right off
Manhattan's Upper East Side back in the
1940s is this safe this is this boat is
very safe okay on the hunt today
professional diver Don Dan and his team
Gan better known as dirty water Dawn is
a regular on Discovery Channel series
sewer divers how many times do you think
you've made this trip now uh I've made
this trip two times a day for three
weeks straight
one of many diving groups who have spent
the last month battling muddy water
rapid currents and fast-moving ships
looking for any sign of the prehistoric
prize the teams as optimistic as
treasure Seekers throughout the ages
this underwater Expedition got started
not with a traditional treasure map but
something far more modern a podcast I'm
start a bone Rush a bone Rush yes sir
The Joe Rogan Experience with its 11
million listeners per episode in
December Rogan hosted Alaskan Gold Miner
and fossil collector John Reeves he says
starting in the 1920s tens of thousands
of Mammoth fossils have been Unearthed
in Fairbanks on what is now his property
some of the bones and tusks were shipped
to New York's American Museum of Natural
History to be studied that is Reef says
until the museum ran out of space in the
40s
they took about
a whole box car load of these bones they
ran out of storage
and he dumped them in the East River
just threw it in the water yes sir is it
still there
I don't know could it be still there
could be some of it maybe certainly the
tusks do you know where it was yes sir
the center of Reef's claim an
unpublished manuscript written about 30
years ago there were thousands and
thousands of Bones sent to the American
Museum in the 30s and 40s so really a
huge volume and maybe they didn't have
storage Robert Sattler an Alaskan
archaeologist is one of the paper's
co-authors he says it's lead author
Richard Osborne who was part of the
original Alaska Diggs heard from
colleagues about the bones being tossed
into the river much like the city used
to dump its snow and the same stretch of
Riverfront as seen here in this 1947
photo but Osborne died not long after
writing the report which laid dormant
for decades until now do you think these
divers are on a wild goose chase my
impression is yes they are but I sang
that I believe there probably are some
of those boats
in the East River someplace but whether
they'll be found I I doubt it
Natural History itself poured cold water
on this already watery Pursuit saying we
do not have any record of the disposal
of these fossils in the East River nor
have we been able to find any record of
this report in the Museum's archives or
other scientific sources
[Music]
but that denial wasn't enough to stop
divers from racing across the country to
hunt for the bones anyway despite the
risks how dangerous is it to dive out
here it is the world's most dangerous
job without this aspect now you're
adding heavy current heavy bow traffic
zero visibility frigid water
temperatures
and the depth so on a scale of one to
ten of danger 10 being the worst it's a
10.
challenges Amplified by a rocky riverbed
once you get down there you'll notice
the bottom is on an angle like this it's
tapered so it goes from 20 feet down to
almost 70 to 80 feet in some locations
and then you can't see your hand here
and you're wearing bright blue gloves
and you cannot see your hand if you
can't even see in front of you how are
you going to find bones yeah get real
close
is that what you're doing yeah you get
real close you gotta go you feel your
hands it's time consuming but you just
keep doing it so far all they found are
old bottles a pickup truck and what
seems to be the city's entire supply of
bike shares but not a single bone yet
they're Deep dive for adventure and
treasure continues you've made 60 trips
out there so far yep
do you think it's gonna be worth it I
yes and no because even if I don't find
anything I could be 70 years old on my
front porch going I tried yeah I won't
live in regret I say I gave it an honest
effort
and there are worse ways to spend a day
oh there's a hundred worse ways to spend
a day
what's fun about all this I mean the
chances of something actually being
found are slim to none right but at the
same time this speaks to the power of
the podcast but also the power of
Adventure and it seems like a lot of fun
there's always hope it's still amazing
that a boxcar full of woolly mammoth
bones you would just say we got no room
for it let's dump it right exactly I
mean museums have ways of storing things
that they don't have room for displaying
and it's certainly usually not throwing
it in the East River so when they find
those City bikes and the other like
things people have thrown away they
don't pick them up and take them out and
I mean sometimes they let people know
but I think there are so many city bikes
if you were to take every single one out
you'd be there for a long time
exactly thank you so much